we do believe that vaccinated people are
much safer when they're wearing those
masks indoors
if you are fully vaccinated you can shed
your mass you know this months ago
months ago
they were all lying to you you can take
off your mask if you're vaccinated
well who's been telling you that for
months on end who's been saying that
but every time we have said that for
months on end we have worried that
youtube will take down our videos or
that apple will somehow
censor us or that facebook will hit us
with a fact check why well because
your public health experts have been
lying to you see here is the thing and
this has been a thing throughout the
pandemic
science is a process science is rooted
in data it's rooted in hypotheses which
are then either falsified
or held up by the data science is not in
fact a group of quote-unquote
tusk scientists okay it is not a it's
not an institution
science is not anthony fauci science is
not richelle wolenski science is not any
of these jokers
science is a process of verifying truth
or falsity
and so those of us who have been looking
at the data all along knew
that once you are vaccinated and you are
two weeks past your final vaccination
you don't need to wear a mask anymore
in fact in these very offices i was very
into masking because i didn't want to
infect
my parents i was very into masking up
until the point at which they got
vaccinated
and i got vaccinated and at that point i
said to everyone in the offices
if you don't want to wear a mask and you
have the option to get vaccinated
if you choose not to get vaccinated
that's a you problem
if you choose to wear a mask that's a
you problem once you're vaccinated you
don't
have to care i've been saying this for
months you know why because i read the
studies
you know why because i followed the data
you know why because i didn't listen to
the dullards
in the public health establishment who
have been infected with politics we were
told for a year
that donald trump infused all of his
coveted response with politics
and they pointed to his supposed
pressure on the cdc which the cdc denied
and they pointed to his so-called
pressure on anthony fauci without you
which fouchy denied
okay and then joe biden came into office
and the
the entire public health establishment
just started mirroring whatever joe
biden wanted politically
they started going soft on whether
schools should reopen even though the
data said that schools
should be open they started suggesting
that vaccines weren't all that effective
they started suggesting that
workplaces should continue to socially
distance even after people have been
vaccinated joe biden was appearing
publicly
20 000 feet away from anybody outdoors
and he was still masking kamala harris
was kissing her husband
on tarmacs through a mask even though
both of them had been vaccinated
none of this was in compliance with
science all of it was politically driven
bullcrap because as i said
the goal of the biden administration was
to gin up a feeling of panic and
unease and unrest so that they could
foster all this massive
government growth the idea was that if
we are in the middle of a crisis then we
still need more government and that of
course was using every crisis as an
opportunity and if the crisis was
already on the wane as it has been for
months
then you just manufacture a feeling of
crisis
okay so yesterday the public health
experts decided based on no
new data none that
everything i've been saying for the past
several months is correct okay now it's
very important to note here
the timing again all of this data has
been widely available
for months it's been available since
february and march and we have known
since even before then that if you had
covent and you had developed antibodies
to covet
you were not going to infect anyone yet
everybody was busy screaming at rand
paul suggesting that if rand paul
stripped off his mask he was going to
infect people
that was not true okay rand paul
happened to be correct about that
i know because i was talking to people
who are actual epidemiologists i was
talking to people who are actual doctors
like dr marty mccary over at johns
hopkins university
and yet we were told by the public
health experts the institutional
know-it-alls that you had to listen to
them even if what they were saying
was not in consonance with the science
this is what happens when you have an
idol worshiping society
when people have determined that there
are people who know more than everybody
else and their expertise this cult of
expertise
has to be paid attention to even when
the experts are speaking not from their
own expertise but via politics and you
can tell
because experts are able to show their
work experts are able to tell you why
they think the things that they do
every day on this show for months we've
been playing clips of rashfolensky
unable to explain our own policies
we've been playing clips four months of
fouchy being unable to explain
what the hell he's talking about and
then if you say that
then your social media bettors shut you
down because you're not speaking in
consonance with the cdc well the cdc was
not speaking in consonance with science
how do we know
because again none of the data changed
they changed all their standards
yesterday and the reason they changed
all their standards yesterday
to tell people who were vaccinated that
now finally they could unmask had
nothing to do with science
it had nothing to do with data it had to
do with the fact that joe biden had a
terrible couple of weeks politically
it had to do with the fact that
inflation is starting to hit and hit
really hard and not enough people are in
the workforce
and joe biden has to encourage people to
get back into the workforce because if
we don't have enough people
back in the workforce going back into
their regular lives inflation is going
to spiral out of control
that's what this has to do with okay so
the white house's new announcement the
sort of triumphal announcement you can
take off masks
what it really exposes is not that we
beat covid we beat coveted months ago
what it really exposes is that so much
of this has been politically driven and
remains politically driven
and if you ask me for my outcome from
this who i trust and who i don't
i'll tell you who i trust big pharma who
actually came up with the actual
solution to this thing
i'll tell you who i don't trust the
government sources who lied to you every
step of the way
and i don't mean that they made mistakes
making mistakes is understandable
in the early days of the pandemic there
were a lot of mistakes made
understandable it was a novel
coronavirus we didn't know all that much
about it
but then it became overt lying and we've
had overt lying for months on
end and that becomes clear when finally
they tell the truth okay so yesterday
the white house puts out an announcement
via twitter in the middle of the day
big news from the cdc if you're fully
vaccinated you do not need to wear a
mask indoors or outdoors in most
settings
we've gotten this far whether you choose
to get vaccinated or wear a mask please
protect yourself until
we get to the finish line okay so here's
the thing even the cdc guidance is
stupid because the cdc guidance says
that if you're vaccinated you still have
to wear a mask if you go on a plane for
example
why why there's no reason for it
they say if you're on public transit you
still have to wear a mask they say
that if there are stores that ban you
from coming inside without a mask
even if you're vaccinated that that's
perfectly okay as well
they say that if you're in a doctor's
office that you're supposed to still
wear a mask even if you're fully
vaccinated
okay this is all stupidity now some of
this is rooted
in another level of ideology which is
how do we tell who's vaccinated and who
isn't and if we remove the mask rules
then
what if unvaccinated people take
advantage of this to unmask
along with the vaccinated people and the
answer is if you are vaccinated
you should not care nancy pelosi said
that she is not going to change the
rules on the house floor
she said until everybody is vaccinated
i'm not going to change the rules on the
house floor
why everybody there's had the
opportunity to be vaccinated if they
don't want to be vaccinated that's them
problem there's a small subgroup of
people
who do have a problem that small
subgroup of people are people who
literally cannot get the vaccine i'm not
talking about it's unavailable to them
because the vaccines are available to
everybody at this point
even if you have to drive a little bit
okay the the vaccines
there are some people who can't get them
for actual medical reasons
okay for those people there are n95s
available for those people their masks
available
they have to protect themselves
understood but the notion that the rest
of society is supposed to continue
masking up and not going to work
is ridiculous okay so even the cdc's
current standards make no sense
but again the the reason that i'm rather
ticked off this morning is because the
people who claim to speak in the name of
the science
never did and now that they are speaking
in the name of the science they claim
they were always speaking in the name of
the science
so they're retconning history they lied
to you for months now they're telling
you the truth and because they're
telling you the truth today
they're suggesting they were telling you
the truth all along and that is untrue
this is all politics the experts are not
interested in conveying you to the data
they're not interested in conveying to
the science they are interested in what
gets
joe biden where he needs to go and if
they and joe biden was stuck in this
sort of catch-22
where the coveted pandemic had to be
extended in order for him to get
his jollies in terms of policy and then
it turns out that his policy jollies
were undercutting
the health of the the american economy
and he was feeling the blowback then
he has to shift one or the other right
either he has to shift his policy or he
has to shift
the coveted pandemic talk or both and
that's exactly what you are seeing right
now this has nothing to do with science
and everything to do with politics
yesterday richarlinsky who just three
weeks ago based on no data at all was
suggesting that
doom was on the way rochelle wallenski
who less than a week ago was suggesting
you needed to continue masking
even if you'd been vaccinated despite
all of the data
this public health expert right science
has an institution versus science is a
process rachelle malenski she says you
know what now you can take off your mask
anyone who is fully vaccinated can
participate
in indoor and outdoor activities large
or small without wearing a mask or
physical distancing
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing the things that you had
stopped
doing because of the pandemic once you
are fully vaccinated
two weeks after your last dose you can
shed
your mass okay and then she says you
know what you know what drove this what
drove this is science of course
now here's the thing have i been any new
studies nope not a one
not a one we knew this months ago months
ago this is uh precisely what i was
trying
to to get out with the the director of
the ctc dr olenski when i spoke to her
after
um so and she she was asked twice about
this during the conference once but once
by caitlyn
and she sort of dodged it saying you
know there's going to be more guidance
forthcoming on this
the science sort of sort of applies
still here it still applies right the
science is
indoors large gathering or small
gathering if everyone is vaccinated
uh you don't need to wear masks okay
sanjay gupta is in the science the
science chan
the science didn't change anything okay
the science has been known
it's been known you know how i know that
because i've been saying it for months
and every time you say oh you're a
science denier no i'm a scientific
institution denier i don't believe that
these quote unquote institutions have a
monopoly
on the process of science and they
demonstrate their
their unverifiable nonsense every single
day
it's incredible to me okay it just
pisses me off that for months we were
told
that you were somehow putting people at
risk when you were not
they this administration undermined
vaccines this administration for months
had your biden out there telling a week
ago he was telling you it was patriotic
to mask up
after you and your friend were
vaccinated if you were sitting in close
contact you should ask
because you're patriotic he said that
last week
and now magically you can take off the
masks forever and the answer is
had nothing to do with science yes he
created vaccine hesitancy
yes he undermined the american economy
yes he was lying to you
they were all lying to you okay you'll
remember that just a couple of weeks ago
maybe a week ago there was a a cdc
masking chart that was put out right it
was supposed to change the standards
for what you can do if you're fully
vaccinated and it said that if you were
outdoors you could unmask if you were
fully vaccinated
and even if and then they said that if
you're fully vaccinated
you still had to wear a mask if you went
to a crowded outdoor event like a live
performance parade or sports event
and everything indoors you're supposed
to mask and you'll remember i went
through this chart in detail
i went through every line of this chart
and i said everything on the right hand
side of this chart is a lie
go back and watch the tape everything
that says fully vaccinated people that
you're not supposed to do
it's a lie you can do all of these
things and you don't need to ask for any
of them i said this two weeks ago
okay and then and then we were so
worried about social media
that youtube was going to give us like
check marks and take down our videos
because this is what social media does
it had nothing to do with facts okay so
here here's the new cdc graphic by the
way oh wait it looks exactly like what i
told them to do go back and look at the
tape i literally
honestly we should pull the clip of me
saying what this chart should look like
versus what the chart now looks like
they are identical
okay it's the whole thing is ridiculous
on its face
it's ridiculous so anthony fauci came
out
yesterday he said you know what we have
to get rid of restrictions so people can
get
like it can feel like they're getting
back to normal what i i have a question
where is anthony fauci what have you
done with him where is the real anthony
fauci where did you get this imposter
here's anthony fauci saying maybe this
will cause people to get vaccinated this
is the same administration
that refused to acknowledge that you
could go out and live life after getting
vaccinated
this is the same administration that
undermined vaccines
by suggesting that we had to pause the
jnj rollout because there were six cases
out of six
million people who had blood clots and
here's anthony fauci
then you know maybe maybe this will
encourage people to get vaccinated you
know he's been saying this for months
right here he's got two thumbs in saying
that this guy
here's anthony fauci what we're doing
now with the relaxation
of the restrictions on people who are
vaccinated
is trying to get back to a degree of
normality which
people who get vaccinated deserve to
have that that's been one of the things
that's been the concern
saying if i get vaccinated what
difference is it going to make my life
hasn't really changed that much
well now your life is going to change
that much for people
who are not vaccinated this might be
an incentive for them to get vaccinated
okay so
it's amazing now he's saying what is
scientifically true
so is he lying before is he lying now
for the left amazingly they're saying
he's lying now
the left is like well i don't even know
why they're saying we should take off
our mess maybe you should
wear our masks forever first of all let
me just say this you are a sheep
you're a sheep if you are wearing a mask
now if you're wearing a mask and you've
been vaccinated it's because you're a
sheep
there is you're free you're free to be a
sheep it's a free country
but you are you're living life in fear
for no reason these vaccines are
unbelievably effective
even your own garbage administration is
telling you that okay but
anthony fauci i love this the flip in
time is just incredible i mean
you could you're getting whiplash here
here's anthony fauci saying you know
this is a step in the right direction
yeah we noticed
i wouldn't go so far as to say it's
essentially over i think this is a very
important step in the direction of
trying to get back to some degree of
normality
because this is something that everyone
has had on their mind you know i'm
vaccinated
when can i start doing things a little
bit more in the normal trend
and being able to go around without a
mask indoors as well as outdoors
is really a big step in that direction
so i wouldn't want to declare victory
prematurely but i'm saying
this is clearly a step in the direction
that we want to go unbelievable by the
way how bad is the whiplash here here's
how bad the whiplash was
yesterday afternoon they announced that
cdc announced that if you
had been vaccinated you could take off
your mask just before that joe biden had
had a meeting
in the white house with the house
minority leader and the house majority
leader
and the and the speaker of the house and
and all the various
leaders of the various parties everybody
in the room had been vaccinated
and there's a picture going around of
every single person in the room wearing
a mask
and so a senior biden advisor andy
slavitt
who's been wrong on three quarters of
this stuff andy slavitt a coveted
advisor to biden was asked
so why was joe biden masked he is
vaccinated everyone in the room is
vaccinated here was andy slavitzander's
answer yesterday
yesterday morning before the cdc
announced that by the way you can take
off the mask
i'm not sure that the president is the
average uh person i
i personally think there's a lot of
protections around the president why
does he need lots of secret service
agents why does he
why do they you know belt and suspender
everything with the president because
he's a very important person
and i think you shouldn't take your mark
just by what you see in the oval office
i think most people
if you're indoors around other people
that are vaccinated cd says it's okay
and i think you should listen to the cdc
on that i mean it's unreal so basically
he has no rationale
whatsoever but they were still
promulgating this crap knowing that it
was crap and then the cdc changed its
standard
later in the day again all this had to
do with the fact that joe biden is a
giant failure of a president
and because he's a failure of a
president he needs to declare early
victory remember the original date they
were going to declare victory was july
4th
why because they wanted the symbolic
victory on july 4th and because they
were hoping that before july 4th they
could ram through these trillions of
dollars in spending then it turns up the
inflation blew up
it turns out that joe manchin and
kristen cinema weren't going to go along
with it
and so joe biden had a choice i can
continue to foster this this
world-beating
giant spending agenda and blow out the
economy in the process
or i can walk this thing back a little
bit and so he decided
yesterday that it was time for a new
news cycle that's what this really is
about
don't talk about manipulation of science
on behalf of politics this is it
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
so you stay up to date with all our
future content